it takes a tough machine to make the
mountains of popcorn movie theaters go
through every night one of the things
that's important to to the theater
customers when they come in as they want
fresh popcorn and at gold metal products
this fun food is serious business we are
never satisfied we are always looking at
ways to improve the way the world pops
popcorn popcorn isn't just popular in
the United States the appeal of popcorn
around the world is just fabulous last
count we've sold popcorn machines and
related gold motor products to 190
countries of the some 200 countries that
there are in the in the world and they
make them all from scratch at their
Factory in Ohio ninety-five percent of
the parts start life here as plain old
sheet metal we make tens of thousands of
different parts so each sheet as it
starts out may make one or two hundred
different parts machines cut it stamp it
even mold it into parts every movie goer
knows we make tens of thousands of
popcorn scoops and the first stage
blanks the shape it forms it a little
closer on the handle and then it
completely closes the handle for the
final part but the she's can't do
everything
these popcorn makers are so complex
workers have to assemble and wire them
by hand and check this out a big popcorn
popper like this uses over 300 feet of
wire if you look at all the wire we use
in a year that's almost 200 miles of
wire to build the heart of the popper
the popcorn kettle workers mount the
heating coils the stir rod and the shelf
when they're done the kettle alone
weighs almost 50 pounds tempered glass
in a popcorn hopper finish it off the
whole assembly process takes up to three
days and when it's done this machine
puts out mind-blowing amounts of popcorn
twin kettle popper will pop a thousand
pounds of popcorn and an eight-hour day
luckily this addictively salty crunchy
snack one movie star that never goes out
of style
we love popcorn a goal model watch
cooking channel for more great episodes
of unwrapped
you